[Music]  my mission is to empower young people to  be able to make a change in their school  in the community in their education  system  [Music]  in the last years we faced several  challenges from 2008 financial crisis we  have been through a lot of budget cuts  on education we have also seen our space  for participation shrinking and young  people and school students in particular  not being consulted on matters that  concern them last but not least covet 19  hit us hard and it hit hard particularly  the mental health of school students all  over europe  [Music]  europe gave me a chance to meet other  powerful incredible women other women  leaders that helped me to feel more  empowered to make a change and lead in a  transformative way  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you